it's been said that you can't please
everyone all of the time that's
especially true for movie endings
Hollywood history is full of shocking
finales that have left people confused
made moviegoers mad or sparked fierce
debate between critics from decades old
films to modern day blockbusters here
are some of the most controversial movie
endings of all time
major spoilers ahead obviously Monty
Python's Life of Brian once a surefire
way to stir up controversy make a movie
about Jesus
it works for Mel Gibson Martin Scorsese
and of course Monty Python okay
technically life of Brian isn't about
Jesus at all it's about a guy named
Brian who gets mistaken for a messiah
and ends up getting crucified and while
our reluctant hero dies a painful death
all the guys hanging on crosses around
them launch into an upbeat musical
number
ah
[Music]
needless to say a life of Brian made
some people pretty upset protestors sang
hymns outside movie theaters and the
film was banned in some countries for
decades the Catholic Church Jim dinner
made up their own rating for Life of
Brian ac4 condemned harsh but despite
the notoriety or more likely because of
it
life of brian have since become a comedy
classic Titanic sure Titanic is still
the second highest grossing movie of all
time
but those billions of dollars couldn't
save the film from endless scrutiny
according to countless fans across the
world the ending of Titanic is nothing
short of a disaster after the boat goes
down Jack and Rose find themselves stuck
in the freezing cold waters of the
Atlantic then the jacket freezes to
death it's this scene that sparked two
most of the outrage wasn't their room on
that piece of wood for the both of them
to the debate was so intense that in
2012 Mythbusters dedicated an entire
episode to discovering the answer with
the help of director James Cameron they
determined that if Rose had just tied
her life jacket to the underside of the
door there would have been enough
buoyancy to hold them both but Cameron
doesn't buy into that argument saying
the script says Jack dies he has to die
maybe we screwed up the board should
have been a tiny bit smaller but the
dudes going down in other words through
love is a lie and you should never hope
for happiness geez Cameron Blade Runner
by this point there are seven different
versions of played runner available to
watch and a thanks to all that tinkering
sci-fi fans have spent countless hours
of discussing whether or not wicked
eckhart is actually a replicant so
what's the correct answer well if you go
by the original ending it's a
straightforward no the theatrical cut
ends on an upbeat note with a decade and
as robotic ladylove escaping into the
mountain to live a long and happy life
however that all changed with the
director's cut that's the version in
which Scott added Deckard's unicorn
dream and cut the happy Hollywood ending
this time around the film ends of our
protagonist to finding gasps origami
message implying the cop knows what
Deckard dreams about because Deckard
memories are implants thus making him a
replicant ever since people have argued
about Deckard's true nature even with
Lee Scott and Harrison Ford don't agree
the director firmly believes
that is a machine well the answer fought
to keep his character 100% human
so I resisted the idea of being a
replicant I suppose as a replicant wood
that settles event or does it the missed
the ending of the myth is one of the
bleakest finales ever put the film
directed by Frank Darabont
the mr. focuses on a group of New
Englanders trapped in a grocery store by
a mysterious fog the titular mist is
full of horrifying monsters but things
aren't so great inside the store either
once people start getting sacrificed
Thomas James character David Drayton
makes a break for freedom with a small
band of survivors but unfortunately
there's no happy ending here lost in the
mist with no hope in sight David
performs a mercy killing to spare his
friends and his own son from the
uncoming creatures and the venn are just
a few painful seconds later a group of
army guys show up to save the day and
look for survivors yeah it's bleak grim
and completely different from Stephen
King's novel ah but the author love the
Darabont's twist saying Frank wrote a
new ending that I loved it is the most
shocking ending ever Watchmen even
though Alan Moore's Watchmen is widely
considered the greatest graphic novel
ever written it said quite a while to
get a movie adaptation up on the silver
screen at one point Terry Gilliam took a
crack at the material but when that
didn't pan out
it eventually fell to Zack Snyder to get
the thing made the result was a film
that was pretty faithful to the book
except for one giant major change in
more than regional story the villainous
of the man Diaz destroys New York with a
mocked up a lien squid the arrival of
the monster convinces the world super
powers that extraterrestrials are going
to attack forcing the US and the USSR to
put aside their differences and band
together in order to face the
otherworldly fire however Snyder totally
drops the whole alien sea beast angle
instead of man Diaz blows up New York
and frames your nip attend dr. Manhattan
tricking America and the Soviet Union
into becoming friends to defeat the
naked blue superhero millions of lives
were suddenly ended
in an act of evil perpetrated by dr.
Manhattan excels Snyder has since said
that the squid was cut out so more time
could be spent building the characters
of Manhattan and Rorschach for his parts
he's also acknowledged that the altered
ending was the biggest knock against the
movie so there's that the Dark Knight
Rises
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
was a game changer for superhero movies
and of the final film in the series The
Dark Knight Rises had a lot to live up
to but instead of diving headfirst into
the darkness
the third northern film ended on a much
happier note with the Caped Crusader
saving Gotham from a new to the bomb
before giving up his vigilante ways to
travel the world with Selina Kyle as a
result many fans wondered if this was
some sort of inception style dream
sequence after all the scene plays out
exactly like a fantasy described by
Alfred earlier in the film I had dish
fantasy I would look across the tables
and I'd see you do we don't want
Christian Bale on the other hand insists
Batman happy ending is completely real
my personal opinion is snow was not a
dream but that was for real some people
thought the movie should have gone in a
more depressing direction by killing the
superhero while others were glad that
Bruce Wayne finally got the happy ending
and really we shouldn't have been
surprised by the film's upbeat finale
because as Harvey Dent once explained it
tonight is darkest just before the dawn
this was the dawn audiences have been
promised the gray satin Alaska the grade
follows a hunter named John Hathaway
played by Liam Neeson who stranded in
the wilderness with a group of oil
workers while he starts the movie
suicidal Otway slowly regains the will
to live which is too bad since he winds
up in the middle of a Wolf Den ready to
fight earth way tapes a knife and broken
bottles to his hand but before the final
confrontation the screen cuts to black
movie over what what
audiences were sharply divided some
people thought the ending was perfect
while others felt cheated as for
director Joe Carnahan
he cut the bullfighting finale because
the film had already reached its
emotional conclusion and he also worried
that the sight of CG canines might have
ruin the scene
however Carnahan amidst the promotional
material of the enemy of the film in a
lot of ways I guess it created a promise
that people felt the movie didn't live
up to
snowpiercer directed by bong joon-ho
snowpiercer is set in the middle of a
wintry post-apocalypse worth the last of
humanity on a train that travels around
the world unfortunately living
conditions aren't a picture of equality
folks from the tail end are treated like
prisoners while the people in the front
live like kings so a group of rebels led
by Kurtis played by Chris Evans fights
their way up to the front of the Train
hoping to overthrow the head honchos but
when Curtis makes his way into the
engine he learns the train operates
using child slave labor realizing the
entire system is corrupt and impossible
to save Curtis destroys the Train
possibly killing everyone on board
except for two kids emerging from the
rubble a teenage girl and the young boys
find themselves adam and eve of a frozen
world and as they step into the snow
they see a polar bear assigned the
worldís falling out and maybe there's
hope after all well that's what bong
joon-ho intended anyway saying it's a
very hopeful ending those two kids will
spread the human race but many people
had trouble getting past certain plot
issues as plenty of critics have pointed
out those two kids have lived their
entire lives on the train so they'd have
no hope of surviving the frigid
wasteland and that is if that big old
bear didn't eat them he's going to be
pretty hungry
passengers on paper passengers should
have been one of the biggest
blockbusters of 2016
it starred Chris Pratt and Jennifer
Lawrence two of the biggest stars in the
business and it was based on a
screenplay that many hailed as one of
the best scripts in Hollywood but the
sci-fi flick with a flop grossing a
hundred million dollars domestically on
a 110 million dollar budget so what went
so terribly wrong about passengers well
movie goers were expecting to see a
story about two beautiful people who
accidentally wake up from suspended
animation while traveling to a new
planet unable to return to their pods
the two are fated to spend their lives
to
on the spaceship but the trailers were
more than slightly misleading and it
turns out Chris Pratt's character Jim
wakes up after his pod malfunctions
unwilling to spend his life alone
he selfishly releases senator Lawrence's
character Aurora against her well even a
robot bartender was surprised who's the
lovely lady this is Aurora Aurora
admittedly
the movie could have done something
interesting with this premise but
instead of dealing with Jim's decision
in a mature complex way the filmmakers
have Aurora fall in love with a guy and
decide to spend her life with him even
though he's essentially kidnapped and
murdered her when the rest of the
passengers wake up nearly 90 years later
they find out that Jim and Aurora lived
a long happy life and they grew a bunch
of trees on their spaceship as a result
the critic took the movie hard and the
audience's decided to stay away from
theaters thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out with us cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]